un cap qui ne changera pas malgré une
très légère amélioration de la situation
sanitaire en france le porte parole du
gouvernement a salué les efforts des
français qu'ils encouragent à maintenir
durant cette période de vacances
scolaires aucune nouvelle restriction ne
sera prise même dans les zones où le
variant est inquiète afin je cite de
laisser respirer les français concernant
lé chiffre dans les hôpitaux ils sont en
baisse est la décroissance de malades du
comider de 14 % sur la semaine
le nombre de malades est dans un état
grave se stabilise et le nombre de morts
sur sept jours en moyenne on représente
1 300 décès un quotidien
autre point abordé par le porte parole
du gouvernement
la campagne de vaccination qui fait tant
polémique à gabriel attal a reconnu elle
qu'elle ne correspond pas à la volonté à
des français mais que le gouvernement
allait prendre toutes les dispositions
pour répondre à cette demande écoutez je
veux dire aujourd'hui que la mécanique
est bien en route les centres de
vaccination couvre tout le territoire et
nous fonctionnons en flux tendu nous
avons avec l'europe su taper du poing
sur la table et obtenu davantage de
doses de vaccin le président de la
république a mobilisé toute l'industrie
pharmaceutique et dès le mois prochain
des vaccins moderna seront fabriqués et
produit en france à la suite de cette
mobilisation
les trois quarts des résidents en ehpad
reçu une injection et déjà plus de 20 %
des plus de 75 ans ont reçu au moins une
dose du vaccin
nous allons répondre à l'enthousiasmé de
nos aînés et puis par tranche d'âge
ensuite nous attendrons la vaccination à
l'ensemble des français selon le
calendrier la stratégie qui ont été
prévus et annoncés par le gouvernement
près de deux millions cinq cent mille
personnes ont déjà reçu une première
dose de vaccin soit 3,3 pour cent de la
population a contrario un peu plus de
900 mille personnes ont reçu la deuxième
dose un rythme qui doit donc à
s'accélérer à rien peut tout faire
basculer c'est sur ce terme précis avec
abri à la tall a insisté
c est pour cela qu aucun un changement
de cap n'a été abordé les français sont
nombreux à se demander quand ils vont
pouvoir retrouver une vie normale
malheureusement
ce n'est pas pour tout de suite le
couvre feu qui devait à la base durer 15
jours devrait rester en vigueur et ne
sera pas modifiée tant que la situation
le nécessitera
on se dirige vers un allègement pas à
pas on se concentre en premier lieu sur
les départements les moins touchés
certains membres du gouvernement
attendent par exemple revenir sur la
réouverture de certains lieux publics
comme les musées a compté à du mois de
mars
en revanche pour les restaurants et les
centres commerciaux de plus de 20
millimètres carrés qui sont toujours
fermés ça ne sera pas avant l'été à 2021
selon un certain elle députés bref vous
l'aurez compris le bout du tunnel n'est
pas pour tout de suite